Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Arrow episode 11 video.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet.
We have to talk about all kinds of black canary
Talia al Ghul stuff, so right off the bat.
If you didn't catch the end of the episode.
She says her name is really Dinah Drake the
original version of the black canary from
the Golden age comics her daughter became
Dinah Laura Lance, so I feel like they averted
a giant fandom landmine like people were already
upset because what was going on with Laurel.
But then they saw that this new black canary
was coming in and she wasn't from the comics.
How dare they, but turns out that was a fake
name, so I'm so happy with the way this went
down in celebration of that there's a new
round of the injustice 2 giveaway I'm giving
away a copy of the game.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment about the episode on this
video and just a reminder that giveaway winners
are announced at the end of videos I get a
lot of weird questions about that.
So I'll explain what's going on with Dinah
Drake what the TV shows probably going to
do with her because is not to be so easy she
won't immediately start being Black Canary
but the Talia al Ghul stuff will come back
in present day as well, so top 10 WTF and
comic book Easter eggs.
There were a lot of them.
So the beginning of the episode is sort of
the origin of the Tina Bolin character as
we know her will learn her real name to the
end of the episode.
That's when everyone was screaming.
So we see that she was in Central city.
We learned that she was an undercover cop
trying to take down Sonos who's actually character
from the comics all explained in the second
but basically it's a drug ring she was trying
to take down, so she was there the night of
the particle accelerator explosion so she
got metahuman powers she screaming, so she
basically has sonic abilities in number nine
as we learn her real name is Dinah Drake the
original Golden age version of the black canary.
So what ended up happening is is that later
in the comics during the silver age they made
the mother-daughter thing, so her daughter
became the Dinah Laura Lance character so
when most people think of green arrow black
canary being together in the comics being
a couple that's the Dinah Laura Lance version
of the character the daughter of the Golden
age black canary but in the Golden age comics
during the just a society brave and the bold
team ups she actually meets the green arrow
and they develop a relationship.
So even the Golden age version of the character
was in love with that version of green arrow,
but you after member they rec cons stuff is
the get to the silver age is crisis on infinite
earth.
So the modern version that most of you been
reading this whole time is the younger daughter
version of the character.
The way they set her character up is relatively,
comic book, accurate, she was a police detective
on the TV show in the comics.
Dinah Drake was trained by her father to become
a police detective that he ends up getting
killed and she's denied entry to the police
academy.
So she takes it upon herself to become a vigilante.
So the arrow version of the character is actually
pretty, comic book, accurate, but number eight.
You can kind of see with her back story that
it's a mirror for Oliver's back story he spent
his time on the island.
She had her own version of the island which
was like her undercover work this crucible
that she had to survive she's sort of like
season one Oliver right now with her own version
of the list.
That's what her vision board of death and
revenge looks like is basically Oliver's list.
So in the way that he's come this far since
that original version of himself, the hood,
which will talk about in the second to because
we get to see the season one costume again
and the season one bow she's still in super
stab you mowed in that just their way of showing
you that is not can be so easy like they are
just gonna roll up offer her membership as
you can be like okay I don't want revenge
for my partners death anymore, so what I like
the way they're taking their time in getting
her to actual black canary because she hasn't
taken up the mantle yet she just said that
she's in for her second chance number seven
was the Felicity storyline.
The way they explain this is the Diggle's
freedom would come at the cost of Felicity,
so she's sort of selling out to this darker
crowd.
I know they made it seem kind of cheerful
but she's actually in a be doing some pretty
hard-core illegal stuff, so she still trying
to do good things.
This season, but is just gonna take her down
a very dark path and when they say dark they
been interesting social be doing a lot of
really cool stuff that's what the Pandora
program was it was basically a program for
opening up all this information on really
bad companies really bad people in it might
even end up causing some collateral damage.
Usually when one of the heroes inside the
team do something really dark and make some
big went usually it comes at some great price.
So we just haven't seen the price that Felicity
is going to have to pay to have all this power
number six Oliver finally gets to meet Talia.
It doesn't sound like he totally understands
where she comes from.
She makes some jokes about her age like her
longevity the fact that she's very young she
trains out.
Faye is something of a family secret that
he'll learn about when he gets involved with
the league of assassins later in life as we
seen in previous seasons.
So in the comics Talia is older than Nissa
I totally think they can do some Talia versus
NIST on a future episode if Katrina law becomes
available because she's part of the training
day TV show now she is a series regular.
So just unavailable for arrow.
So I think that open the door for them to
bring Talia on the show, but she sort of setting
Oliver on the path in the first big test is
taking down this human trafficker who's getting
Kovar all this money was all just a big reminder
of who Oliver is he's running from the person
that he needs to be she's trying to remind
him of that that he has a purpose and that
purpose is the list number five was all the
big belly burger.
This wasn't as much of a WTF it was just like
a really fun Easter egg because in season
one.
They actually had a big belly burger said
with a shot a lot of scenes.
So when people say that arrow season five
is going back to it season one roots in the
way tell stories.
The things that it does it is very literally
going back to some big season one things including
number four the original season one costume
in the season one bow with the message that
Oliver reads at the beginning of each episode
where Talia says you need to become something
else someone else that Stephen Amell's voiceover
at the beginning of every single episode,
so the whole thing here is that this is the
last big step is Oliver trains to go back
to Star city and start crossing names off
the list, so we'll talk about the flashbacks
at the end of this because even though.
This is the last season of these type of flashbacks
there still going to use flashbacks when they're
necessary for adding context to scenes, but
is not can it be as big as they been in the
past number three is the Sonos villain which
is kind of like the black canary's version
of Kovar like is that she and Oliver have
this parity between their storylines were
she's trying to defeat her big boss will Oliver's
trying to defeat his in the flashbacks and
just like Oliver during season one year she's
kind of like a season one version of Oliver
she kills them at the end of the episode but
he is a comic book character that was created
by Andrew Kreisberg who's the show runner
on the flash.
He actually wrote the green arrow comic for
a while.
So the Sonos character is just a sonic villain
goes up against green Arrow and Black Canary
during that run.
So I always love it when they do, comic book
characters, but it's even more fun than the
characters were created by actual people that
are working on the show's right now number
two was the world's quickest flash crossover
Marc Guggenheim tease that he said don't blink
or you'll miss it.
It was just that funny moment with her sitting
in the big belly burger and Oliver has to
prove who he is to Capt.
Singh.
I would be surprised if they do little crossovers
like this in the future but were heading in
the sweeps week like we have the gorilla city
episode on the flash, so they tend to do the
biggest things around sweeps weeks.
So if the gonna be a big crossover to be had
or fun moments like this felt time them very
carefully just to get people really crazy
hyped up in number one.
Speaking of hyped up the reveal that she's
actually Dinah Drake.
So it was a nice twist at the end of the episode
like the actress I like the character I like
the way they gave you the explainer for her
across the episode how she sort of like tracks
down all these villains she's a total bad
ass.
He's a former police detective explained that
she has all the skills and she has the command
of her abilities it is needed of someone to
operate on team Arrow so that aside everyone
was really upset because the like we want
a metahuman Black Canary and we wanted to
be like black siren because she was the closest
we got to a green arrow black canary thing
from the comics but when they announce the
character's name was Tina Boland everybody
just got really upset people really upset
last week about the Laurel stuff about the
new black canary stuff but tonight when they
dropped that bomb at the end of the episode
oh.
That was only my cover in a my real name is
Dinah Drake the original version of the black
canary everyone was really excited, there's
always going to be people that are upset for
weird reasons or they really like the actress
and they want her to come back but the way
they explain it is that she is almost beyond
redemption, so she's probably going to still
be evil when they bring her back on.
Now they can do black canary versus black
siren whenever she comes on it will be a lot
of fun.
So let me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode what you think about the
new black canary.
So far and.
She hasn't really picked up the name yet.
So it's probably going to be a couple more
episodes before they explain how that's gonna
work.
So either way I feel like it was a great move
for the show I always one of them to do a
metahuman Black Canary the easiest way to
do that was to use the particle accelerator
explosion in really cool just get you hyped
up for next week they're going to Russia in
present day team arrow is going to Russia
the last time they were there.
I think was during season two so it'll be
a lot of fun.
So everybody make sure you watch next week
to congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner Swift anime please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details I'll name that injustice
to giveaway winner the next time I post a
DC video I've got some Marvel some Star Wars
coming tomorrow there will be game of thrones
probably some new DC this weekend but if you
have requests for arrow flash bonus videos
stuff that happened this week on the TV shows,
just leave them in the comments below while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my black flash legends of tomorrow
and you can click here for the flash episode
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you in the next video!